[Musique]
alors mélanie cette semaine vous emmener
à saint-arnoult-en-yvelines ça va
consommer savard frissonner à la maison
triolet aragon parce qu'elle passe en
mode halloween et les vacances aussi
faut pas l'oublier alors la fête
halloween cela fait bien sûr on s'amuse
à se faire peur on s'amuse c'est
vraiment important c'est de mots lors
deux activités sur deux journées sont
prévues les 25 et 26 octobre prochain
alors la première c'est pour les 8 12
ans avec un cluedo
un meurtre a été commis à la maison
triolet aragon et les enfants vont
devoir enquêter
ok les énigmes à résoudre dans les
différentes pièces de la maison
avec à chaque fois des cartes à
retrouver donkey innocent tel ou tel
personnage qui font en sorte que on sait
que telle ou telle pièce et qualité
armée exclu une fois l'énigme résolue un
goûter attendra les enfants le créneau
du 26 octobre est victime de son succès
il est déjà complet mais la maison
triolet aragon a sans doute proposer un
autre atelier le 27 octobre
le credo c'est donc pour les plus grands
alors pour les moins de 8 ans alors pour
les moins de 8 ans et l'a cette fois ci
les 4 7 ans ils créeront une marionnette
monstrueuse une marionnette chaussettes
alors je pense que ça va vous intriguer
camus écoutez on va avoir bien sûr du
coloriage du découpage donc c'est aussi
un apprentissage un qu'on fait tout au
long de notre vie mais 5 le découpage
est ensuite coller tous les éléments sur
les chaussettes pour en faire un vrai
monstre ou à partir et bien d'une simple
chaussettes et ensuite on va en faire un
vrai monstre ou va y ajouter des dents
des yeux des cheveux un peu dans tous
les sens et ça à faire donc les
personnages de notre compte final alors
je rassure camille pas besoin de venir
avec sa propre chaussette les animateurs
les ont déjà derrière il faudra
réfléchir aux personnages de sa
marionnette
amandine que vous avez entendu proposera
un début d'histoire les enfants devront
créer la suite là aussi un goûter
terminera l'atelier pour les
informations pratiques les ateliers ont
lieu de 15 heures à 17 heures attention
les places sont limitées et les
inscriptions obligatoires toutes les
informations s'affichent en bas de
l'écran
merci beaucoup mélanie poquet pour ses
différentes aussi
et